powerful new storms are building in the
southern plains where five and a half
million people are threatened by severe
weather tornadoes touched down in
several states over the weekend school
is canceled today for more than 150
thousand children around Oklahoma City
that is where the biggest threat is
right now it includes more Oklahoma
where a tornado killed 24 people six
years ago today CBS this morning lead
national correspondent David Begg know
is there David good morning Anthony good
morning the lady who checked us into our
hotel last night said everyone is
freaked out about today six years ago
when that tornado devastated Plaza
towers elementary parents were adamant
there has to be a way to remember the
seven students who died so they put up
these benches and when we got here last
night we noticed a woman sitting by
herself in front of Kyle Davis's bench
it was his mom and as I walked up to
offer condolences this was one of the
first things she said I am very very
proud of Moore public schools for
closing school tomorrow
Mikki Davis says it was the right call
for more public schools to tell students
to stay home today six years ago her son
Kyle was taking cover with his
classmates at Plaza towers elementary
when a tornado ripped through the wall
of Kyle's building collapsed on top of
it
what is it like to be a parent and live
in this area of Tornado Alley it's
caught me no craziness because no one
that you may have to go through it again
I mean not only did I lose him but we
lost our house and tomorrow with it
being like this it's it's very
nerve-racking for Micky and other people
who live here tornadoes are a fact of
life in Oklahoma
dozens of twisters touched down over the
weekend from Oklahoma to Texas storm
chasers came dangerously close to
disaster in Kansas on Friday
the storms funnel cloud pass right in
front of their vehicle no one was hurt
over the road across this region damage
has been extensive just hit a house
right here guys
with new storms approaching Moore
Oklahoma is again in the bullseye Mikki
Davis says she'll be at home with her
daughter today ready to take shelter my
family text each other constantly where
we're gonna be you know this works we're
going in the shelter this is where we're
ad this is where we're at that's right
so everybody knows and it used to not be
like that
but it is now six years ago Miki lost
not only her son but her home was
destroyed she and other parents got
together and said if more is gonna
rebuild schools they have to put in
storm shelters and so the new Plaza
towers Elementary has a storm shelter
but today kids are staying home so if
you are one of the millions of people in
the severe weather threat today if you
have a weather radio get it keep your
phone charged and please stay tuned to
your local meteorologists they are ready
to track these storms Tony
David thank you we sure hope everyone
stays